hello how's it going guys good thank you
yourself really good so it's Chris and
poppy right it is yeah excellent
so I've seen your question you've said
that you are living in Australia have
been in for the last six years yeah
you're wanting to move back to England
and build a portfolio so what do you
want from me
at the moment waiting for citizenship
here in Australia yeah and so that's
going to hopefully come through by March
of next year and as soon as we get that
we want to come back okay and so I guess
the thing that we want to know is we
really want to get started from here
because by the time we get back we
wanted like ideally we want to be
financially able to continue to carry on
with what we want to do yeah and so not
not to start but not place income but
just to be able to pay for everyday
things that make sense so we basically
want to know how we can get started from
here yeah sure without being a being on
the ground being able to look around
places that sort of thing okay so you
wanted so you wanted to vest everything
you wanted to to sort of build a
traditional buy-to-let portfolio or were
you wanting to do sort of clever
creative things like lease options and
stuff like that or were you literally
just wanted to put your money into a
English portfolio so that when you come
to England you've got some cash flow
coming in no we actually want to do like
we've we've followed all the things the
processes that you've done and that's
the sort of stuff that we want to do I
would want to go down that yeah why
don't you tell me your your strategy
then the thing that you're thinking to
do and then I'll see if I can you know
see any see any problems with that or
challenges of that I mean what what have
you got any challenges I mean what what
is it that you wanted to do what's your
plan 60,000 pounds in
in a savings account and England at the
moment and obviously with watching all
of your stuff and kind of realized that
that's not the way to go yeah and so we
rather looking at investing that in try
and spreading it out as much as possible
but we've also my mum has credit 1.8 in
her property at the moment which she
owns and she's struggling with cash flow
at the moment so we were thinking of
potentially setting up a limited company
which would help us get a mortgage as
well and then her potentially announcing
some of her property and whether that
would be more beneficial using some of
that money as well as our 60,000 or yeah
whether we can just do it with that
60,000 cash flow okay that makes sense
so have you currently got any properties
are told you own any houses in in
England or Australia no would you would
you be able to get a mortgage if you
wanted to save for it for instance you
wanted to use that sixty thousand pounds
to put down to a deep pop as a deposit
on a nice big H amount or something
would you be able to do that or do you
not know okay so your mum would be a
mortgage host yes
oh that's cool all right cool so you've
got sixty thousand pounds that you're
ready to invest in England you've also
got a lot of equity that you mom's built
which you can potentially do as a joint
venture so what's your what's your
problem then what's your challenge well
I guess our big challenge is education
and knowing where to start what to
what's the why do we yeah strategy yeah
like we we want to do the courses up
when we come back and we want to we want
to get a mentor and we've been speaking
to number of people and watching YouTube
clips and that sort of stuff but we yeah
we of course and we just never mention
so we don't jump in and do the wrong
thing and then lose that the savings
yeah yeah I mean you don't you
definitely don't want to yeah invest
into something stupid you want to make
sure that you invest it well I mean like
my thoughts would probably be you're
going to be coming back to England you
said in after March next year right yeah
okay cool so what I would probably be
thinking is it would make sense to try
and invest that sixty thousand pounds
really well into something really you
know really profitable and then use that
as like a earn the right proof type of
thing to then be able to prove to
yourselves and also to prove to your mom
what you can do and then once you've
done that capitalize on the money that
your mom's got and do the same strategy
than you did with the 60,000 pounds if
that makes sense
I probably would I'd probably say that I
mean you want to be clear on your
strategy stale but I mean I would
probably be looking with if you've got
60,000 pounds dude does your mum own any
houses in England yeah just that
property to share buy to let property as
well no so she just owns a residential
yes okay so you need to find out if your
mom's happy to be a normally toast for
you that's great
you want to find out what type of
mortgage your mom can get because it
might be that she your monkey your mom
can get a mortgage which he can't get
HMO mortgage or she can't get you know
there might be then what there's
different types of more we just but I
think probably what I would be wanting
still I understand that you know you
want to get mentored and that kind of
stuff but at the same time is you're not
going to be in the country for I know
this off you know 6 12 months per
sentence you like you want to when you
come to England you said you wanted to
be earning you know 27 K and then you
want to push that up to 80 K so I would
be thinking if I was you know I mean the
money in the bank is as you know it it's
shrinking
so just suck they're doing nothing
that's not good at the same time you
don't want to rush in and buy something
stupid I would probably work with a
really good trusted sorcerer I mean you
know we've got people on our on our
books that we use to invest your sixty
thousand pounds into a really good
profitable maybe like a
a six-bed HMO in a really good area that
might give you a profit of between 1,000
and 2,000 pounds per month okay
something's something like that and then
once you've got the money coming in and
it's all completed and it's working that
might take that could take a few months
because things in property do take a
while
but while that when it's all kicking
them it's happening then show your mom
what it's done hey mom this is the
property that I bought this is the
strategy that we used and then you know
raised some equity from from what your
mom's got and do it again you find the
properties you put you use your
knowledge and your contacts but your mom
puts the money in and you can go 50/50
on the profits by how much how much
equity would your mom be prepared to to
work with you on a million okay well
with a million pounds you can do some
really serious damage I mean we could be
talking about doing development buying
land to building properties from scratch
and then refinance and then putting all
our money all kinds of crazy stuff I
mean what we should be extremely
profitable what's your like long-term
goal what are you wanting to achieve
food properly
I guess my Chris here he wearing the
country because he does geology so he
works away on a mine site all the time
and we never get to see each other so
the the the ideal situation is that we
can both live near our families and
stuff back in England and not be away
from each other all this time so we just
would really like to have money coming
in every month really that we can still
be together so so do you need a certain
level of income before you come back to
England yes how much do you living costs
yeah sure and if you came to England
would your only source of income be
property though would you have another
source or
that's why you can apply now to hit the
ground running when we get back yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's very doable yeah I'm
just thinking it depends on your
strategy so to invent to vest you 60
grams I mean to make 27,000 pounds cash
flow from the back of investing 60 grand
that's going to be very tough going
because that's almost 50% return on
investment that you need so I mean you
know you could you could come to England
tomorrow and and make 27 grand a month
from scratch by just getting one rent to
rent deal or or sourcing your deal a
month and passing on to somebody so
there's there's lots and lots of
different things that you can do I'm
just thinking with your situation I'm
trying to think what the best strategy
would be for you that makes sense and
that's good that would cover your your
basic costs to live a normal basic life
and then obviously you'll just want to
build on that right that makes so in
that case you could do the strategy of
that then you could invest the 60 grand
now get income I don't think you'd be
hitting 27k year but it might be it
could be maybe 20 and then you come to
live in England and then you could then
do a combination of I mean if you if
you've paid the cool thing is if you've
paid someone to source your property you
then not only get the property but you
also get a lot of knowledge as well from
it so by the time you come to England
you know you've got the property but
you've also you can duplicate that and
do it again and again yeah look would
you suggest buying your house outright
for like 60 or would you suggest getting
more control in it and you know like a
big um
you know well I think definitely the
latter because if you bought a house for
cash for 60 grams the rent that you're
gonna get on that even if you're lucky a
60 grand house and maybe going to give
you five hundred five hundred and fifty
pounds a month and then you're gonna
have to pay for someone to manage the
property you're going to be left with
you know very like three four hundred
pounds a month cash flow which is only
going to be what like five grand a year
or something tops whereas if you invest
if you put that down as a deposit get
your mom to be a mortgage host you could
buy a big six bed HMO in the centre of
Birmingham or something and then you
could make yeah a thousand or 1500
patter or even more profit each month as
opposed to a few hundred pounds so you
know you leave Virginia money yeah and I
mean yeah service denomination could be
is very profitable I mean again I think
a cello FIFA says I think for your first
two your first investment I actually I
might be a little bit a little bit safer
than serviced accommodation because it's
a very very tried and tested market than
things so I probably with sixty grand
you're going to have not only could you
buy a height ma you probably gonna have
money left over as well because I you
know you only really need like 40 grand
for a hmm so you couldn't do a hang
tomorrow and then keep some money as
cushion so that when you come to England
you still look like maybe 15 20 grand in
the bank which you could then use for
rent to rents you could use for educate
educating yourself you could use for
paying more source of fees I think I
think if I was you my plan would be to
invest forty thousand pounds into a HMO
and a source of to do it I'd leave it
maybe fifteen thousand pounds in the
bank I've come to England next year with
15 grand and then with that 15 thousand
pounds you can then you can then use
that for whatever strategy tickles your
fancy you can use it to begin to build a
little rent to rent portfolio
whereabouts in England do you get a book
[Applause]
Newcastle are interested New Castle's an
awesome area you there's there's some
really good investment opportunities in
Newcastle
I'd probably come to England you may as
well go full time in property because
you've got the time and you enjoy
property you've got what
have given you it giving you an income
just go crazy go full-time in property
come to Newcastle go networking go to
training programs find some rent to rent
to Newcastle use that 15 grand to go
crazy for a few months just educating
yourself and doing rent to rents and
yeah and also to live off a little bit
and then three months after you've come
to England hopefully you'll have a
couple of rent to rent deals you'll know
the market you're educated yourself
you'll have one nice big HMO giving you
a decent income and at that point in
time you'll be in a position we've got a
million pounds equity from your mom that
you can do some really cool stuff with
us I think that would be where I'll be
wanting to go get someone get the
sorcerer to find something in Newcastle
okay and do your company do that would
we be able to say yeah I mean better
sourced I would recommend I don't
personally do get involved in the source
and side of things but we've got a
company that will be able to sort that
for you and fonts in the in Newcastle no
problem so so the the point of the kind
of action points then for you guys is
gonna be another one
find out if you what kind of mortgage
your mom can get can she get a bite
hmmm mortgage so she needs to speak to a
mortgage broker okay number two you need
to speak to a sorcerer who can get you a
nice big HMO in Newcastle yeah yeah at
least five six yeah yeah like and then
number three get your ass to England and
pull your sleeves up
yeah that's a very friend all right have
you got anything else you need for me
right now
so welcome well listen when you come to
Newcastle drop us a message let us know
how it's going and we can help in any
way we were you should you'll love it
awesome see you guys
[Music]